- - Ça se joue à l'échelle
plplanétaire ce genre de dossie.
MeMerci beaucoup.
F Ferry de Kerckhove, ancien
amambassadeur du Canada et
prprofesseur à l'École supérieue
d'd'affaires publiques et
ininternationales de l'Universié
d'd'Ottawa. Quelle lecture
fafaites-vous de ces derniers
dédéveloppements?
- - Vous avez entendu les analys
ququi dit que la porte est grane
ououverte pour la libération des
dedeux Michel. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fafait de cette lecture des deux
dédéveloppements? Quelle a été
l'l'élément déclencheur selon-vs
enen coulisse?
- - Il y a deux éléments,
prpremièrement je crois que la
ChChine elle-même en aval du ra-
lele-bol de toute cette affaire
ququi ne cessait de lui donne un
poportrait
ququi s'ajoutait au portrait. E-
cece que le dialogue entre Biden
etet là l'exécutif a été mis sur
lala table ce que j'admire de la
papart de Joe Biden. Je crois qe
totout le monde veut en finir.
LaLa pression montait et le sort
dedes deux Michael devenait de
plplus en plus embarrassante por
lala Chine. Je pense que c'est
vrvraiment cette pression, maisl
y y a aussi effectivement la
rerelation étroite Canada
amaméricaine où Biden avait pros
dede faire quelque chose.
SoSon secrétaire d'État égalemet
etet je crois véritablement que
c'c'est cette espèce de lassitue
etet en plus de ça, elle voulait
auaussi rentrer au pays. Je cros
quque l'ensemble de cette mesure
etet j'ai craqué un climat de
tetension internationale sur
lelequel Monsieur Biden voulait
memettre un peu la pédale douce.
ToTout en étant toujours fixés r
lala Chine, Biden voulait aussi
évéviter d'être enfin chargé sie
pupuis dire dans de petites
afaffaires comme celle là aussia
popolitique internationale.
- - On sent bien que ce dossier
papar le fait même celui des dex
MiMichael était inter relié qui
s's'enlise en mer de Chine.
MoMonsieur Biden qui s'en est
pépétri, bref, pour la suite des
chchoses, pour les deux Michael
jujusqu'à quel point ça peut alr
vivite à partir de ce moment-ci.
CÇa fait plus de sanctions
dederrière les barreaux.
- - Je suis très heureux de voir
ququ'on a mis, il connaît
l'l'acheminement, j'ai tendanceà
didire que les chinois ont
mamaintenu au tout début de
l'l'affaire et progressivement s
onont lié. Ce qui fait que ils
vovont prendre un certain temps.
IlIl y a deux éléments d'abord
sasaveur a déjà été jugé. 11 ans
dede prison il sera extradé. Mas
COCOVID n'a pas encore vu son
jujugement. Est-ce que les chins
vovont accélérer la procédure pr
prprocéder exactement de la même
mamanière. Et on leur envoie en
mmême temps que savoir au Canad?
AÀ ce moment-là, les chinois sot
enencore juridiques, on fait ce
ququ'il devait faire. C'est-à-de
jujuger les des personnes,
ilils avaient déjà installé pour
sasavoir l'extradition si je pex
didire à la fin de son
ememprisonnement. Mais c'est
ququelque chose sur lequel le
gogouvernement chinois a tout bn
sesens a diminue la peine et
rerenvoyer les deux en même tem.
DoDonc moi je dirais que ça va
prprendre plusieurs semaines avt
quque ça se déroule. Je ne pense
papas qu'on verra les deux
MiMichael, j'aimerais tellement
leles voir ici, ça va prendre
enencore un certain temps.
- - Soyons patients, mais bons l
fafaut quand même revenir sur la
CaCanada et les relations avec a
ChChine. Depuis longtemps le
CaCanada est un véritable et au
cocontre la Chine et les États-
UnUnis. Deux poids-lourds sur
l'l'échiquier mondial. En quoi e
dédénouement qui est en cours et
s's'accélère peut changer nos
rerelations avec le géant chino?
- - Je crois que nous allons
prprogressivement cesser d'être
leles otages de nos deux otages
pupuis dire.
PaParce que du moment qu'ils
sosoient libérés, la donnée
nonouvelle, ça va prendre un
cecertain temps, et nous avons
ququand même des intérêts
coconsidérables. Marek Mack
prpréoccupation est-ce que les
chchinois vendent des conditionà
lala libération des deux Michael
cocomme par exemple que nous
emembrassons ou à oui alors que
totout le monde un peu plus à
cacause des problèmes avec la
ChChine. Je ne pense pas. C'est
popour cent qui va prendre un
cecertain temps et il y a une
vévéritable réflexion ce qui esà
pepeu près tant sur la nature ds
rerelations qu'on va voir avec a
ChChine. N'oubliez pas que
lala vision européenne et la
vivision européenne de la vision
avavec la Chine est très
didifférente. Les Européens sont
bebeaucoup Pierre Arcand commerr
enen dépit de toutes les problès
avavec les droits de la personne
etetc. Tandis que du côté des
EÉtats-Unis, la Chine est
vévéritablement l'opposant
prprincipal avec lequel on doit
gégérer. Alors le Canada va devr
trtrouver si vous voulez un espe
dede conduit entre ces différens
tetendances qui sera ralliera
dedevant ajouta Robert en
prprétendant du côté de qu'est-e
c'c'est la dragée haute.
L'L'opération sera en finesse qe
nonotre gouvernement est assez
sosophistiqué pour le faire? Je
n'n'en sais rien. Je ne suis pas
coconfiance pour cent. Il y a tp
d'd'intérêts, regardez simplemet
lele nombre d'étudiants chinois
quque nous avons pliés dans les
dedernières décennies au Canada.
QuQui renforce la capacité nos
ununiversités. Y'a tellement
d'd'éléments qui jouent que je
crcrois qu'il va y avoir et vers
unune reconduction faite avec
lelenteur
ilil y avait quand même une
cecertaine retenue, mais je e pe
quque nous allons devoir
reredécouvrir la chaîne à moins
quque d'autres histoires
susurviennent, ce qui n'est jams
papassé.
- - Ce qui n'est jamais impossie
efeffectivement pas rapide dans
totout ça
lala tenue des JO à Pékin dans
ququelques mois.
LeLes chinois vont vouloir
didissiper les histoires qui
popourraient leur nuire.
- - Tout à fait, je crois que la
ququestion électrique vous faite
lala soulever, le Canada n'aura
papas beaucoup de raisons à part
l'l'affaire des deux Michael,
c'c'était la plus seyante. Je
pepense qu'effectivement
nonous allons probablement le
reretrouve Jeux olympiques et ns
avavons gagné la médaille d'argt
OKOK.
- - Espérons-le. Et tout ça sera
didiffusé sur les ondes de Radi-